non Geneviève Darius sec bonjour nous
sommes au cœur de la 26e édition de la
Semaine européenne pour l'emploi des
personnes handicapées et c'est
aujourd'hui le duoday on y reviendra
puisque pour l'occasion vous n'êtes pas
venu seul le thème de cette 26e édition
se présente sous la forme d'une question
à quand le plein emploi pour les
personnes en situation de handicap et il
est vrai que la situation
s'améliore certes taux de chômage des
personnes handicapées à baissé mais il
reste tout de même encore deux fois plus
élevé que dans l'ensemble de la
population active absolument donc nous
sommes à la manoeuvre et
particulièrement pendant cette semaine
qui nous permet de mettre en avant
les possibilités
d'emploi des personnes handicapées leur
capacité et puis aussi tous les modes de
formation adaptés qui existent
aujourd'hui et qui permettent à ces
personnes de tout simplement d'acquérir
un peu plus de compétences et de pouvoir
rentrer dans l'emploi donc cette semaine
est très importante parce qu'elle
sensibilise chacun
fait que et bien il n'y a que la
compétence qui compte et c'est ce que
nous voulons mettre en avant cette année
l'emploi des personnes handicapées est
une obligation pour les entreprises il
faut le rappeler elles doivent
normalement représenter 6% de la masse
salariale le service public n'est pas
très loin de ce chiffre avec
5,44% en revanche dans le privé on est
assez loin du compte puisqu'on est à 3,5
c'est à dire à peine plus de la moitié
de ce qui est requis comment on explique
ce décalage parce que dans le public
l'État a plus de moyens de pression
écoutez peut-être qu'il y a une
sensibilisation mais même dans le public
nous sommes pas à 6%. donc moi je ne
suis pas satisfaite et il y a des
disparités importantes
la fonction publique par exemple
territoriale et peut-être meilleur que
la fonction publique d'État donc nous
avons dans chaque ministère dans chaque
administration nous avons encore
beaucoup de travail donc moi je ne m'en
satisfais pas mais dans le privé il y a
encore une marche plus haute avec des
situations très diverses selon les
secteurs et selon la typologie des
entreprises dans les grands groupes on
retrouve facilement un chiffre qui
s'améliore notablement par contre dans
les PME les TPE il y a une moindre
sensibilisation donc moi j'ai vraiment
demandé avec Olivier du soft ministre du
Travail à l'agefip qui est l'organisme
qui aide à cette intégration des
personnes en situation de handicap dans
les entreprises d'avoir d'être
particulièrement sur le terrain auprès
des PME des TPE parce que ce sont des
entreprises qui
brute massivement et surtout le
territoire français compris dans les
zones rurales dans les zones
moins denses que les métropoles
c'est pas forcément limpide pour tout le
monde
c'est le levier de la formation est très
important et celui-là vous voulez
l'actionner aussi fort que possible la
formation c'est essentielle d'abord
c'est essentielle pour la population en
général et donc c'est essentiel aussi
pour les personnes handicapées elles ont
des compétences j'étais hier par exemple
dans une réunion qui restituait vraiment
des actions formidables pour dans le
domaine du numérique
et bien les personnes handicapées qui
ont des compétences dans ce domaine là
peuvent suivre des formations et avoir à
la clé immédiatement des emplois parce
que c'est un domaine qui recrute
beaucoup et quelquefois il faut aller
chercher ses compétences parce que ce ne
sont pas des personnes qui ont des
cursus
scolaires voire universitaire classique
donc il faut aller repérer ses
compétences faire des formations et
mettre les gens en emploi c'est tout à
fait possible c'est fait et nous devons
être très proactif pour poursuivre dans
ce sens il y a aussi des efforts à faire
pour simplifier les démarches pour les
entreprises oui alors là nous avons du
travail pour un travail de
simplification
global arrive française
c'est une maladie française et nous
avons véritablement un travail global à
réaliser ça rentre dans les axes forts
que nous voulons
mettre en oeuvre pour la prochaine
Conférence nationale du handicap il faut
simplifier simplifier les démarches pour
les personnes handicapées mais
simplifier également les démarches pour
les employeurs tout est trop complexe et
il y a il n'y a pas suffisamment de
transversalité et de possible tout est
en silo donc nous devons décloisonner
pour être plus efficace il faut aussi
faire changer les mentalités et c'est
l'un des premiers objectifs de ce duoday
je rappelle que cette opération qui en
est aujourd'hui à sa cinquième année
consiste pour une entreprise une
collectivité ou une association a
accueillir pour une journée une personne
en situation de handicap qui va donc
former un duo avec une personne un
professionnel qui s'est portée
volontaire et vous êtes donc venus
aujourd'hui avec Marie Lemière avec
laquelle vous formez cedio bonjour Marie
Lemierre bonjour vous êtes étudiante en
Master 2 de géographie alors je sais pas
si on dit option mais en tout cas
biodiversité territoire et environnement
qu'est-ce que représente pour vous cette
journée du diodet c'est une journée
importante c'est une journée où le
handicap est reconnu où les personnes en
situation de handicap peuvent passer une
journée avec une personne valide donc
c'est important pour le rentrer dans le
milieu de l'emploi tout simplement
d'avoir une connaissance de ce milieu et
d'avoir une reconnaissance aussi par ses
pères valides tout simplement et d'être
de ne pas de cloisonner le handicap à un
secteur et de faire
ma commune valide et Handicap qu'est-ce
que vous avez peut-être l'impression de
pouvoir apprendre d'une certaine manière
à la ministre à l'occasion de cette
journée je pense que ça peut être un
moment d'échange aussi sur nos
difficultés qu'on rencontre au quotidien
passez une journée aussi c'est ouvert
nos difficultés quotidiennes que l'on a
avec un handicap c'est pas toujours
facile à percevoir et c'est surtout ça
c'est un moment d'échange et pouvoir
apprendre à prendre de l'autre et
apprendre à
votre handicap n'est pas toujours
visible puisque il évolue parfois d'une
journée à l'autre d'une semaine à
l'autre est-ce que c'est encore plus
difficile lorsque on est atteint d'un
handicap qu'on dit invisible est-ce que
c'est plus difficile que pour les
personnes dont le handicap est
immédiatement compréhensible d'une
certaine manière oui si c'est beaucoup
beaucoup plus difficile déjà accepté
pour la personne en situation de
handicap la personne qui vit le la
maladie et le handicap mais aussi un
problème de reconnaissance que ce soit
par les administrations je pense à la
MDPH tout simplement qui qui reconnaît
pas voilà la maison des personnes sur
son handicap ou la CPAM voilà toutes ces
toutes ces administrations qui ne
reconnaissent pas forcément le handicap
puisqu'il n'est pas figé n'est pas fixe
et il évolutif et après parfois même
dans le milieu puisque vous vous avez
voulu intégrer une équipe paralympique
et quand vous a dit non parce que vous
n'êtes pas suffisamment handicapé
il y a des critères pas assez valides
dans une tranche intermédiaire dans
laquelle je peux pas destiner à une
pratique paralympique ou une pratique
plutôt de sport classique Geneviève
Dario sec un duo comme cela évidemment
c'est c'est très bien mais qu'est-ce qui
se passe après
bien écoutez aujourd'hui
moi je suis très très contente parce que
nous avons plus de enfin plus de 20300
duos qui ont été formés l'an dernier il
y en avait 17000
nous en avions 17000 et en 2021 il y a
eu à peu près un duo sur 5 une personne
handicapée sur cinq qui a trouvé une
solution ou un stage ou un emploi dans
l'entreprise ou elle avait fait ce duo
donc moi je trouve que c'est prometteur
aussi ça permet de découvrir et puis ça
permet aussi quelquefois d'avoir des
opportunités de pouvoir rentrer
directement dans l'entreprise donc voilà
cette journée aussi elle est importante
pour les entrepreneurs et pour les
handicapés 30 secondes mais peut-être
faut-il rappeler en quelques mots que
l'emploi des personnes handicapés ne
nuit pas à la productivité voire au
contraire l'emploi des personnes
handicapées ne nuit absolument pas à la
productivité
et amène un climat social tout à fait
différent dans une entreprise merci
Geneviève de Rieussec merci Marie-Laure
bonne journée merci